[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und anne gellinek
guten abend demokratie lädt ein so
salbungsvoll hatte die bundesregierung
den tag der offenen tür betitelt bei dem
bürger gestern und heute in berlin den
kanzler den wirtschafts und den
finanzminister mal von nahem sehen und
befragen konnten und die bürger rannten
der politik die bude ein laut starke
proteste sowie mitte der woche in
neuruppin gab es nicht fragen aber schon
heike slansky hat für uns zugehört
lächeln für eine momentaufnahme im
sekundentakt der kanzler als attraktion
eine seltene gelegenheit politik trifft
auf bürger ein fest für politisch
interessierte oder einfach nur
neugierige
erwartungen ich freue mich einfach nur
dass die möglichkeit mal wieder gibt in
den in das bundeskanzleramt reinzukommen
und dass man es einfach mal hautnah
erlebt wo die mächtigen hier so
herumlaufen ja was mir dass
möglicherweise eine persönlichere ebene
mit dem kaster heute möglich ist wenn es
keine offizielle pressemitteilung ist
dass man auch ein bisschen lockerer die
fragen von ihnen beantwortet bekommt der
kanzler zwar betont locker unmittelbar
vor seiner kanada reise steht rede und
antwort so wie man ihn kennt die themen
vielfältig der krieg in der ukraine
das neun euro ticket weitere
entlastungen ernstes und heiteres
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wenn man weiß wieviel die meisten
bürgern und bürger verdienen ja der
andrang war im beliebtesten minister
deutschlands ebenfalls hoch habeck der
vizekanzler gibt sich erst einmal betont
volksnah
ganz selten wochen musste der tag der
offenen tür eine stunde für fragen und
sorgen vor allem vor dem winter die
hohen gaspreise die
versorgungssicherheit gelingt ist
deutschland 15 bis 20 prozent gas
einzusparen dass es viel dann haben wir
eine richtig gute chance mit den
genannten maßnahmen über den winter zu
kommen
überzeugungsarbeit und trotzdem bleiben
bei manchen zuhörern zweifel
allen maßnahmen da die richtige
zielgruppe zu treffen es wird
möglicherweise den leuten die wirklich
gar nichts haben als auch rentner
arbeitslose wenig helfen als steckt wäre
wichtiger diese gruppe zu unterstützen
der bundesfinanzminister ebenfalls in
seinem element eine verlängerung des
beliebten 9 euro tickets lehnt er ab
eine über gewinn steuer auch die fdp als
verhinderer in der koalition meinungen
dennoch hat er mich nicht überzeugt ich
bin generell auch größer werden müssen
ein euro ticket und die kommentare die
er da gemacht haben mit der gratis
mentalität fand ich halte generell ein
bisschen abwerten er ist nur zürich und
es gibt viel zu wenig in sachen
klimaschutz was angestoßen wird und wir
rasen in die katastrophe die regierung
arbeitet fieberhaft an einem weiteren
entlastungspaket doch der finanzminister
bleibt dabei wir müssen es innerhalb der
grenzen der schuldenbremse und ohne
steuererhöhungen finanzieren bei der
inflation bekämpfen müssen und die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung stabilisiert
werden muss bei der tour des kreises
ja ich habe nie behauptet dass der job
des finanzministers jetzt bequemer
spaziergang ist kein leichter gang für
den kanzler bürgernah und trotzdem
abgeschottet
seine ampel rumort es hinter den
kulissen wird heftig gestritten ausgang
offen
die preise steigen so viel ist klar doch
wie hoch die nebenkosten für gas und
heizung wirklich werden das wissen
bislang die wenigsten denn die meisten
stadtwerke und energieversorger haben
ihre abrechnungen noch gar nicht
verschickt st ingbert im saarland war
schneller hier haben die verbraucher ist
nun schwarz auf weiß und die freude
darüber hält sich in grenzen anselm
stern und susanne freitag berichten
es wird gerechnet vielerorts in
deutschland auch bei familie becker im
saarland es wird teuer so viel ist
sicher nebenkosten plötzlich ein
hauptproblem
134 euro im monat mehr
nur abschlag
bei und anja bäcker haben gerade post
bekommen vom gasanbieter die stadtwerke
st ingbert erhöhen die preise um bis zu
60 prozent sehr bald ab dem ersten
oktober heißt hier konkret auf ihren
bisherigen abschlag von 248 euro kommen
134 euro obendrauf
382 euro im monat nur fürs gas und auch
das ist noch nicht alles die gaspreis
umlage die von der regierung jetzt auf
die endverbraucher die gas benutzen
umgelegt wird das kommt ja noch und
obendrauf das habe ich noch gar nicht
ausgerechnet weil das wird dann wohl
auch von unserem anbieter mit eingezogen
drei kinder haben die beckers beide
eltern arbeiten voll sie bei einer bank
er in der autoindustrie die massiven
mehrbelastungen können sie wohl
irgendwie wegstecken vielen geht es da
ganz anders unser nachbar sehe auch drei
kinder jetzt kommt noch ein kleines kind
nach nur ein verdienst muss man schon
schauen wie es weitergeht das wird schon
probleme massiv geben denke ich
vor massiven problemen vor viel mehr
armut in deutschland warnen verbände
etwa verbraucherschützer immer mehr
kostet das ganz normale leben einkauf
strom heizen sprit besonders dramatisch
für die die besonders wenig verdienen
und keine rücklagen haben wenn es über
einige monate gegen dann könnte man mit
ratenzahlungen auch mit
überbrückungshilfen mit stundungen bei
energieversorgern und beim etat mietern
noch argumentieren aber wir richten uns
ja auf zwei bis drei jahre energiepreise
in dieser höhe ein und das ist nicht zu
finanzieren
das kann nur die bundesregierung
aushelfen und das geht sehr teuer werden
deswegen hundert prozent konzentration
auf die von armut bedrohten haushalte
krisen krieg die folgen immer wieder
wird all das diskutiert auch bei familie
becker nina macht sich sorgen um die
eigene und die allgemeine lage
ja ich würde heute gerne im nächsten mal
ausziehen wie ich mir das halt
finanzieren kann einmal als student hat
man jetzt auch nicht so viel geld und
ich denke dass dadurch die
zweiklassengesellschaft super sich teilt
einfach das noch mal stärker hervorhebt
dass man sich auf einmal gedanken machen
muss kann man am abend weg liegen gerade
unter freunden der anerkanntesten der
andere nicht was kann sich wer noch
leisten eine frage dieser energiekrise
die so vieles so viel teurer macht und
uns live zugeschaltet ist jetzt die
ministerpräsidenten von
mecklenburg-vorpommern manuela schwesig
von der spd guten abend nach schwerin
guten namen frau galli nick frau
schließlich werden gerade die sorgen von
menschen gesehen denen die ersten
rechnungen ins haus geflattert sind
gleichzeitig leicht jetzt leistet sich
die regierungskoalition den luxus den
ganzen sommer über die entlastungen
munter zu streiten wann wird olaf scholz
eigentlich seine richtlinienkompetenz
benutzen und sagen wie das dritte
entlastungspaket aussehen soll es ist
wichtig dass diese antwort jetzt zügig
kommt denn einerseits wird gesagt dass
es teurer wird und auf der anderen seite
wissen die menschen nicht was gibt es
eine entlastung es gibt ja schon ein
erstes entlastungspaket das ist gut das
wird zum beispiel der familie helfe die
wir eben gesehen haben wenn beide
berufstätig sind kriegt jeder 300 euro
und für jedes kind noch 100 euro dazu
bedeutet letztendlich 600 euro für die
eltern noch mal 300 euro für die kinder
und das während der 900 euro als
konkrete hilfe das problem ist dass aber
dieses energie geld zum beispiel nicht
rentnerinnen und rentner bekommen nicht
studenten bekommen auch nicht solo
selbständige und wir erwarten dass es
genau für diese personengruppen
ausgeweitet wird denn es gibt gerade
viele ältere menschen die mit wenig
rente klar kommen müssen und die müssen
zum beispiel auch unterstützt werden
genau die kritik ist ja dass das
bisherige paket sozial nicht ausgewogen
ist also wie kann man diese schieflage
verändern indem das energie geld ganz
konkret für personengruppen ausgezahlt
wird die eben kleine einkommen haben das
sind rentnerinnen und rentner auch
studenten solo selbstständige und
gleichzeitig muss auch
müssen dinge weiter fortgeführt werden
die sinnvoll sind und vernünftig sind
und das ist zum beispiel dass neun euro
ticket
war das klug eine eine gasanlage zu
beschließen ohne sich vorher genau zu
überlegen wie man die leute eigentlich
entlastet weil so wie es jetzt ist hätte
man das geld doch eigentlich besser
gleich den unternehmen geben können oder
unsere landesregierung hat bereits im
märz den gas decke gefordert den
gaspreis deckel vorgeschlagen es gibt ja
ein solches modell wo man sagt dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger 80 prozent des
durchschnittlichen energieverbrauch es
zu einem festen preis bekommen und das
gedeckelt wird vom staat unterstützt das
würde helfen dass man auch
planungssicherheit hat denn die meisten
sind jetzt total verunsichert und machen
sich sorgen wie teuer wird es wie werde
ich klarkommen wenn man jetzt die
gasanlage gemacht so wie es die
bundesregierung vorgeschlagen hat dann
muss man aber im gleichen atemzug sein
wie entlastet wird man kann nicht erst
die belastung rausschicken und nicht
sagen wie und wo wird entlastet ihre
partei ist ja in der bundesregierung und
deshalb die frage wie wird das denn
finanziert sie haben sich für eine über
gewinn steuer ausgesprochen
fdp finanzminister lindner lehnt sie
aber ab also wo soll das geld herkommen
also zum einen ist es ja so dass der
staat sowohl bei der banken und
wirtschaftskrise als auch bei der korona
krise viel geld in die hand genommen hat
um wirtschaft und bürgerinnen und bürger
zu schützen und das war richtig wir
haben zum beispiel in der korona krise
einen großen schutzschirm aufgespannt
denn auch hierbei der energiekrise
werden ja wirtschaftsunternehmen auch in
große schwierigkeiten geraten stadtwerke
kommunale unternehmen und bürgerinnen
und bürger das ausmaß ist viel größer
als bei kronau und deshalb muss der
staat helfen es kann gar nicht anders
gehen aber wie soll das finanzieren wäre
ja die dass der grundsatz wir sind ja
noch gar nicht dabei dass wir uns auch
so ein schutzschirm schutzschirm
verständigt haben ich muss mich
entschuldigen ich höre alles immer
doppelt und dreifach fällig kann es
anders gemacht werden dann kann ich
versprechen entschuldigung und wie soll
das finanziert werden also wir
unterstützen ganz klar die über
gewinnsteuern dass auch keine radikale
linke idee wieso manche tun sondern es
ist eine frage der steuergerechtigkeit
dass die einen die jetzt die belastung
tragen
und die anderen die davon gewinne machen
dann ja wohl die die gewinne machen
einen teil dazu beitragen dass man die
die belastung haben entlastet das ist
eine frage der gerechtigkeit
und dafür sollte man sich öffnen in
deutschland sie sind ja
ministerpräsidentin des bundeslandes das
im bundesschnitt die geringsten
einkommen hat sie werden also mit vielen
unzufriedenen bürgern zu tun kriegen wie
wollen sie verhindern dass extremisten
von rechts und links zulauf bekommen
sich auf das thema draufsetzen das thema
der galoppierenden preise in dem wir das
tun was wir seit vielen jahren tun uns
ganz konkret für die belange der
bürgerinnen und bürger einsetzen und
deswegen werben wir dafür dass das
energie geld ausgeweitet wird wir morgen
einen großen energiegipfel mit allen
akteuren im land mit der wirtschaft aber
auch mit den verbraucherschützern mit
den stadtwerken und es geht jetzt drei
dinge zu tun erstens wir müssen mehr
energie mehr gas einspeisen da helfen
wir über mecklenburg vorpommern über
lubmin wird die infrastruktur von nord
stream die durch nord entstanden ist
genutzt um lng zusätzlich einzuspeisen
damit wir energie sicherheit
gewährleisten können zweitens wir müssen
energie sparen das ist ganz klar und
drittens wir brauchen ein
entlastungspaket und wir wollen uns zum
beispiel morgen auf ein härtefallfonds
verständigen aber der wird nicht
ausreichen wir müssen gemeinsam etwas
mit dem bund machen wir müssen konkrete
antworten geben die ängste und sorgen
nehmen dann haben die erstmal wollen wir
das für die bürger tun und dann haben
die extremisten die wenigste
angriffsfläche aber wir müssen damit
rechnen dass natürlich solche
politischen extremistischen kräfte eine
solche situation ausnutzen werden jetzt
gibt es ja die forderung von fdp vize
chef kubicki nord stream zwei zu
genehmigen damit mehr gas fließen kann
sie kennen sich ja ein bisschen mit
pipelines aus ist das eine gute idee
diese frage stellt sich nicht die hat
die bundesregierung klar beantwortet und
wir müssen jetzt die kapazitäten nutzen
es ist ja durch die infrastruktur von
nord stream eine große verteilen
infrastruktur entstanden weit über
mecklenburg vorpommern hinaus wir können
von hier aus mit der verteilung fr
struktur
ostdeutschland bis nach tschechien
bayern und süddeutschland versorgen das
passiert ja auch und da sind kapazitäten
und wir arbeiten mit hochdruck daran
jetzt mit den versorgern die es möglich
machen können energie einzuspeisen um
ihm zusätzlich gas zu haben da hilft
mecklenburg vorpommern für große teile
von deutschland also es bleibt beim aus
für nord stream zwei sagt manuela
schwesig ministerpräsidentin von
mecklenburg vorpommern herzlichen dank
für das gespräch nach schwerin ich danke
ihnen einen schönen abend und danke dass
es noch mit dem ohr geklappt hat und
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit den
nachrichten von gundula gause in der
diskussion über einen nachfolger angebot
für das 9 euro ticket das zum monatsende
ausläuft warnen die verbraucherzentralen
vor preisanhebungen bei bussen und
bahnen die chefin des bundesverbandes
pop schlägt ein bundesweit gültiges
monatsticket für 29 euro vor es brauche
ein günstiges und einfaches angebot sie
forderte politische unterstützung für
den ausgleich der mehrkosten
die ursache für das fischsterben in der
oder ist immer noch nicht geklärt jetzt
spricht die polnische umweltministerin
von fake news aus deutschland nachdem
die behörden in brandenburg überhöhte
pestizid werte festgestellt haben
experten sehen darin aber nur einen
grund von mehreren für die
umweltkatastrophe
die polnischen behörden stehen in der
kritik weil sie zu zögerlich über das
massenhafte fischsterben berichtet
hatten
in somalias hauptstadt mogadischu haben
sicherheitskräfte einem terrorangriff
auf ein hotel nach 30 stunden beenden
können seit freitagabend hatten
islamistische extremisten das gebäude
attackiert und belagert mindestens 21
menschen kamen nach behördenangaben ums
leben über 100 wurden verletzt bei den
gefechten wurden auch teile des hotels
zerstört die islamistische terror miliz
al shabab reklamiert die attacke für
sich
heftiger monsunregen hat im norden und
osten indiens zu überschwemmungen und
erdrutschen geführt mindestens 40
menschen sind dabei ums leben gekommen
viele werden noch vermisst
städte und hunderte dörfer wurden
überflutet häuser von wasser oder
schlamm mitgerissen die bewohner mussten
in notunterkünften schutz suchen dabei
erschwert anhaltender regen die
rettungsaktionen
bei einem autobomben anschlag nahe
moskau ist die tochter eines russischen
ideologen getötet worden die usa sehen
den rechtsnationalisten alexander doudin
als ideen stifter für den russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine laut
ermittlern explodierte das auto gestern
abend während der fahrt russische medien
vermuten eigentlich sei der
rechtsnationalisten des anschlags
gewesen seine tochter daria dubina eine
29 jährige journalistin hatte seine
positionen vertreten den krieg
verteidigt und ukraine als unmenschen
bezeichnet
der ukraine krieg greift über das land
hinaus das könnte eine schlussfolgerung
des eben gesehenen attentats von moskau
seien sicher ist dass die ukrainische
armee versucht russische urlauber von
der besetzten krim zu verscheuchen
drohnen und raketenangriffe auf die
halbinsel zeigen wirkung der tourismus
auf der krim hat sich halbiert auf
ukrainischer seite gibt es schon lange
keine ungestörte ruhe mehr odessa die
hafenstadt am schwarzen meer ist auch
eine ferienregion kenner hebestreit hat
dort menschen getroffen die ein bisschen
normalität versuchen da wo nichts mehr
normal ist auch mitten im krieg reifen
die melonen rundum odessa gibt es am
straßenrand viele solcher stände doch
die bauern haben in diesem jahr mehr zu
erzählen als ihre früchte anzupreisen
wir leben wie auf einem pulverfass wir
wissen die was die nacht bringt es kommt
schon vor dass unsere jungs auf dem feld
sind und eine rakete abgefangen wird und
hier abstürzt neulich ist eine
durchgekommen und in der nähe
eingeschlagen das haben wir am ganzen
körper gespürt
die erschütterung muss gewaltig gewesen
sein die rakete hat diese ferienanlage
bloß ein paar kilometer entfernt
getroffen eine tonne sprengstoff hat die
zocker hawaii apartments in stücke
geschlagen sie sind für ihre schwester
in russland die berichte über russische
angriffe offenbar für propaganda hält
diese leute leiden schreibt sie ihm ihr
handy es sind einfache menschen wie ich
die hart gearbeitet haben sie dir das an
ihr macht alles kaputt
es war nicht der erste angriff das
feriengebiet liegt in der nähe einer
strategisch wichtigen brücke die
geschosse sind offenbar nicht besonders
zielgenau
mein haus hat es ganz schön erwischt
fenster und türen sind kaputt und auch
das dach ist zerstört keine ahnung wie
wir das schaffen sollen vor dem winter
wenigstens das dach zu reparieren damit
es nicht reinregnet
mitten in odessa so etwas wie alltag
müde nach einer weiteren nacht
unterbrochen von luftalarm besuchen
viele an diesem wochenende den markt sie
bummeln durch die hallen aber ihr geld
ist knapp
es gibt hier eigentlich alles zu kaufen
aber die preise sind stark gestiegen
karpfen vor allem bietet aljona an seit
die fischerei auf dem meer schwierig
geworden ist sie verkauft 60 prozent
weniger fisch als im letzten sommer
viele männer hier haben ihre frauen und
kinder ins ausland geschickt und sind
jetzt ganz allein zu haus klar kaufen
die jetzt weniger
wer kann nutzt das wochenende für einen
ausflug an den einzigen vom militär
freigegeben badestrand eine stunde
außerhalb odessa können sie ein wenig
abschalten aus der pharma andré bei
diesem beach club mitten im krieg
zusammengezimmert
das leben geht ja weiter und wir müssen
ja irgendwas tun wir haben nur dieses
eine leben und das müssen wir
das denken sich auch die einen ausgang
zu teuer sind familien picknick am
strand mit fleisch am spieß
wir sind jetzt nicht so entspannt wie in
friedenszeiten aber das wird schon
wieder werde ich es für einen nachmittag
immerhin ist der krieg ein gutes stück
weit weg
und hier jetzt nochmal gundula mit
nachrichten vom sport bei der
schwimm-europameisterschaft in rom gab
es am letzten tag noch einmal gold für
deutschland leonie beck aus würzburg hat
das zehn kilometer freiwasser schwimmen
mit einem starken schlussspurt für sich
entschieden die 25 jährigen sind die mit
einem vorsprung von gerade mal 1,8
sekunden im offenen meer vor der
italienerin générale thaci wegen
ungünstiger wetterbedingungen war das
rennen mehrfach verschoben worden
in der fußball-bundesliga bleibt bayern
münchen weiter an der tabellenspitze
der rekordmeister siegte klar auswärts
beim vfl bochum mit sieben zu null und
in dem anderen sonntagsspiel trennten
sich zuvor ein frankfurt und der erste
fc köln 1 zu 1 unentschieden für die
deutschen athletinnen und athleten sind
die europameisterschaften in münchen
sehr erfolgreich zu ende gegangen platz
eins im medaillenspiegel und auch jetzt
gerade im moment wird im olympiastadion
ordentlich gefeiert denn gerade eben
setzte die deutsche sprintstaffel der
frauen um gina lückenkemper noch einen
drauf und holte gold am letzten
wettkampftag war zuvor bereits
tischtennisspieler d'anjou aus würtingen
überraschend europameister geworden
sensationell viele medaillen fuhren die
deutschen kanuten 1 zum abschluss holten
martin hiller und tamer sproßmann im
kajak zweier über 1000 meter den
em-titel und außerdem holte
speerwerfer julian weber aus mainz am
abend gold und erfüllte sich damit einen
traum
das gibt es also auch in deutschland ein
riesen sportfest in einer großstadt tage
lang und keiner meckert ganz im
gegenteil veranstalter sportler
zuschauer und politiker alle sind
begeistert großartig wunderbar
sensationell sind die adjektive für die
european championships in münchen die
heute zu ende ging und weil es so
überraschend schön war träumt die
lokalpolitik gleich schneller größer
weiter richtung olympia stefan leifert
zieht eine bilanz des wunders von
münchen
und wieder kommen an diesem letzten tag
die tausenden in münchens innenstadt
noch einmal dieses feeling erleben das
seit tagen die stadt verzaubert
finale im straßenradrennen der frauen
quer durch münchen und wieder ist da
dieser rausch die begeisterung und eine
rührung die wohl nur der sport erzeugen
kann
[Gelächter]
man fährt alle an also alles sind ja
begeistert die stimmung ist grandios was
mir und mehr biss den familien da ist
wenn paare da ist sind von jung bis alt
ist einfach alles da man nur
verschiedene sprachen
münchen ist mit den european
championships ein betörendes
sommermärchen gelungen elf tage 9
europameisterschaften und über 1,2
millionen menschen die sie live sehen
wollte ob in den straßen der stadt vor
historischer kulisse oder im 50 jahre
alten olympiastadion die verschmelzung
von event und statt von sportlern und
publikum ist aufgegangen
zwar waren sind wie das publikum mit
gegangen ist er ich glaube so was erlebt
man nicht oft in der sportler karriere
und ich bin einfach unheimlich dankbar
dass ich das hier erleben durfte das ist
einfach nicht nur fachpublikum was man
dann in den jeweiligen hallen vorfindet
sondern einfach sportfans sport
begeisternde die da einfach sich das
anschauen wollen und mit dabei sein
wollen und teil dieses ganzen sein
wollen ein bisschen staunt münchen auch
über sich selbst in diesen tagen so viel
begeisterungsfähigkeit hatte sich die
stadt nach all der korona lethargie
nicht zugetraut nicht nur der sport
gehört in die erfolgsformel sondern auch
die orte zum chillen zum mitmachen und
ein üppiges kulturprogramm die
championships sind die geschichte eines
plans der aufging ich glaube wir haben
auch neue standards gesetzt indem wir
sport und kultur miteinander verbunden
haben wir haben immer gesagt dass rufs
festival ist unsere zehnte sportart war
es gibt einfach menschen die können mit
sport nichts anfangen und auch die
wollten wir einfangen münchens zu
zeitlose wie ikonische sportstätten von
72 erleben ein spektakuläres revival
noch heute absolut instagram und
olympiatauglich olympia auch diese
fantasie hat der zauber von münchen neu
beflügelt der traum von olympia in
deutschland einem olympia das so sein
darf die münchen es vorgemacht hat auf
der grundlage das so zu gestalten dass
sich offensichtlich die allermeisten
münchnerinnen und münchner und viele
andere besucher aus ganz bayern
deutschland aus europa damit voll
identifizieren können und sagen ja so
ist es in ordnung und darüber sollte man
es jetzt schon noch einmal nachdenken
ohne die begeisterung die wir jetzt
erlebt haben für olympische spiele
glaube ich nicht als olympische
bewerbung in sinn machen würden das
heißt des ioc ist es ihm mächtig bewegen
und den veranstaltungsorten deutlich
mehr spielraum bei der gestaltung lassen
dann könnte man darüber nach dem lange
nicht mehr hat ein sportereignis in
deutschland so viel lust auf mehr
gemacht die championships gehen zu ende
ihre momente bleiben für die ewigkeit
münchen hat vorgemacht wie zeitlos schön
der sport sein kann und wie wenig es
dafür braucht
und wie immer am sonntagabend schauen
wir noch darauf was die nächste woche
bereit hält anna kaiser mit dem ausblick
auf
[Musik]
der suche nach neuen energiequellen sind
bundeskanzler scholz und
wirtschaftsminister harbeck heute
nachmittag für drei tage nach kanada
aufgebrochen
es wird vor allem um die zusammenarbeit
bei grünem wasserstoff gehen dazu soll
am dienstag ein abkommen unterzeichnet
werden
genau am ukrainischen nationalfeiertag
wird der russische angriffskrieg gegen
das land ein halbes jahr andauern seit
1991 feiert die ukraine am 24 august
ihre unabhängigkeit in diesem jahr
stellt sich kiew auf russische
luftangriffe ein großveranstaltungen
sind abgesagt
der bundesgerichtshof wird am donnerstag
die entscheidung zu den revisionen im
mordfall walter lübke verkünden
vergangenes jahr wurde der
rechtsextremist stefan ernst wegen
mordes zu lebenslanger haft verurteilt
alle parteien haben revision eingelegt
am freitag mit in italien offiziell der
wahlkampf starten nach dem sturz der
regierung draghi stehen ende september
neuwahlen an in umfragen führen die
rechtsextremen fratelli d'italia um ihre
parteichefin giorgia meloni
das wetter in der neuen woche wird
wieder sommerlich und ziemlich heiß
morgen scheint bei mais 23 bis 30 grad
neben quellwolken oft die sonne nur in
ostsachsen und südostbayern verdichten
sich die wolken und es kann etwas regnen
dort bleibt es bei 16 bis 25 grad auch
am dienstag fällt nur im äußersten
südosten etwas regen sonst gibt es viel
sonne und es bleibt auch über die mitte
der woche trocken bei 24 bis 33 grad
und das war es von uns morgen freuen
sich marietta slomka und kaiser berichte
hier im heute journal auf sie ihnen
einen schönen abend und schüssen
[Musik]